and uh call this a quorum
and um there's uh money is
representative Bickford and this is
representative Moulton
and so we're here for uh HB uh 618 which
is relative to wage garnishment which
I'll support uh payments
um
do we have anyone that wants to speak to
this
uh bill at this time okay
very good
uh the niche you and I okay
um I don't know if you had a chance to
look at it very much it it does break it
breaks down into really two sections
um your first section
which to move from your two months which
is now one month
in order to uh be in a rear edge
would uh trip some federal is that what
they is that what we had said at the
last committee meeting in March because
I don't recall that well are we
personally the system is one month oh I
see it now for in a rearage uh the bill
asked to go with two months
okay well no I wouldn't have I don't
think I'd have an issue with it however
it does trip these Federal issues which
a researchers
okay so let's title 4D
Security Act of 75. so I just want to
take some notes So So currently
this
would go to two months
but then there's possible that it could
interfere with federal law yes
and we can't do that
well we can however it if you look at
the analysis on the back page it'll trip
all these
um
possibility of losing Federal funding
of 13.6 million in federal funds and
then 1.2 million dollars incentive funds
and 1.9 million of TANF law Grant
twelding so those would go to the
individuals who are in a rearage
no this is B to the state this is the
funding I actually could be reduced Okay
the reason I know this because I dealt
with wage assignment in the past and
they brought in it and we didn't like
the new laws they were coming forward
because it was mandatory
and they came up from Boston and said uh
you do this we're taking 21 million from
you now I I think it was 20 months the
whole but what does the state do with
that money
run their operations
so we don't want to do that well why
don't you child support uh system is
funded two-thirds by the federal
government okay and you know and New
Hampshire puts in the third
one
oh yeah she emailed us this
um
I guess my question is
if this is going to the state
but it's blocked because we changed this
what is the state doing with this money
that we would no longer be able to do
because we wouldn't get this money
um I think you'll find there
um
their Computing systems depend on this
money I believe
as well as
um
enforcement
um probably their attorneys some of it
but they would they the the federal
government has the right to reduce what
they give them because they're out of
compliance now with federal law sure if
we go to two months right so then that
makes me think that we shouldn't do that
okay
what do you think I agree with you at
this point anyway so we're gonna
um you know I have my philosophies today
but I don't think this is the time or
place to do it sure in there power ever
moving to the second part which is here
okay
in number uh paragraph three
uh they're talking about creating a
standard form
um to Enlighten people about what they
can do because we have it in the law
but apparently people aren't being told
this is the law
and not everybody has an attorney I
recall that from from March okay yeah
which
sounds good to me that does sound good
so and that's why we retained this was
because we wanted to I I recall this now
um because we wanted to change a little
this so we want to keep this as the one
month but we want to keep this part
a lot of things we have done that in the
past we've told them to Enlighten the
public as they come in and right so I
was surprised to find that this didn't
happen yeah so can we get them isn't
that a process that they can draft that
now
um to change this part too yeah we could
just have them
leave it leave it as is right this would
be a new paragraph added that would be
an amended one here I believe so is does
that come to You Christina are you the
one that drafts this to no okay do you
have to take it down let's go downstairs
and we'd bring back a uh an amendment an
amendment okay or can we email it to
them
sure
okay so what we want to do we just want
to make a recommendation to the club uh
sure other members right and that's fine
um because we can do that at the
executive section so what we want to do
we want to remove
section two about
income
assignment
and we want to but we want keep three
yeah they'll have to make a little
changes because this is we don't want to
say final divorce because it's not it's
not about divorce it's about
children sure
um right and not and not every situation
is a divorce it's just a child support
right exactly so I put down bio before
final
or the that's it could be final I guess
um change right yeah
during the process and I I am not sure
where the process begins now
for child support they have referees Now
help
to buy them before hearing
okay
um but this part everything else was
good here if they just if they take all
this out then this is all right number
one a would probably say but they would
they'll know what to do they should just
because this is the notification
shall notify each party of their income
assignment wages right for child support
will be automatic under the RSA unless
both parties come to an agreement other
another category down here income
assignment yeah the Department of Health
change
Support Services shall develop a
standard form right that's kind of
interesting
how they did that she does 1A
do we want this to change to be instead
of Health and Human Services Bureau of
I think it's I think it's I think that
is correct because they come on to
Health and Human Services oh okay I
think the vision is okay I don't I don't
know that
so let me let me just write the question
if
where's that here
three
should say
Bureau of Child Support Services
instead of
um and then and then that's it right
that's then oh what was it what did we
want down here
um well it's interesting because when
you that's me really this amendment
conflicts with Federal 45 uh the one
that we talked about 100 what could we
have right which is up here and number
two that we're eliminating which states
that the income of the non-custodial
parent doesn't become which is this is
what flagged us to need to put into
something it demonstrates what happened
in the past it hasn't been corrected for
environment at the federal level yes
because they're still calling people
non-custodial parents right and we don't
do that anymore right a person that pays
is is
non-custodial oh yeah which I always
it's a great offense to because it means
in a sense you're not really apparent
yeah and it and it has someone has to
pay so yeah but well both people should
see the child so yeah and we've come a
long way if a lot of people don't think
so but we really have in
this whole methodology part though this
is this part all in the this isn't in
the uh right but it doesn't go into the
RSA
no right okay this is just for our
right unless you're okay so I can send
and I'll send you
um I'll I'll
Cc or to it um so OLS
and then house bill
and I'm just going to do exactly what we
divorce
section
10 entirely
and then three i a
change
at the final divorce
hearing
two
i n b four
here
thank you
all right okay let's see who would
please make the following change
you wanna okay
yep uh remove section
two
okay happens three or one three one a
we wanted to change
the name it you know just a consistency
section two remove three a change
right
okay
calmer after the three
is it well it's three and then it goes
down yeah all right yeah so three eyes
I don't know we can always check with
them
um
yeah you've captured it is that all of
it
well I put down standard form because I
don't know why it needs
if it's just a form you know it doesn't
need do we need a tone that needs to be
standard I think I think so but okay I
think just standard form meaning goes to
everybody why don't you can you uh CC
Matt Hayes you have this uh address
over at child support
no
I don't think so I only have who comes
up in the
in the
in your email thing right Christine
would know you want me get it from her
sure
she'll come back she will yeah you're
confident
she always does she just gonna show up
too I know you should late though so
that could be most anytime right right
Matthew Hayes is who
he's the uh the child support attorney
that comes here that's been assigned to
the legislature got it well there's also
uh Susan uh person
who he works for and then of course is
the
yeah
I think a woman that runs the whole
thing
but we yes ordinarily would use Matt
Hayes
yep oh I'm sorry
sure no problem so because the the
current bill you need to see the bill or
you got in front of it now okay good
okay so the way the current bill is
written it conflicts with federal law
and it would deny and that's what he was
explaining to me in the beginning that
um that there would be a conflict with
with federal law and that would
um prohibit some State funds from coming
in
so uh so what we wanted to do and this
is the whole reason why we retained it
in committee was because we wanted to
fix these little issues
um so what we want to do is remove
section two entirely
because switching it from it's currently
one month if we switch it to two months
that's when we start this conflict with
federal law
um
for Section 1A so I'm a little out of
order but
um it's just a wording issue where we
just want to fix the language
um no no I'm I'm up here oh you still
are up there yeah so one one a I'm sorry
um
we just want to just take out the word
divorce in divorce hearing because not
every child support hearing goes in line
with a divorce like it it could and it
frequently does but there can also be
like engaged couples that break up or
boyfriend girlfriends that that break up
um
and then down in three one a again it's
more just a language thing
for the same rationale as one one a
uh
we don't want it to say final divorce
hearing we wanted to say by and before
hearing
just because it might not be a divorce
situation and we don't want there to be
um
confusion
as to you know if there if someone was
in like a boyfriend girlfriend and they
need to and they need to get child
support we don't want them to be like oh
they don't fit under this law because
it's not divorced so we just want to
clean up a little bit of language but
that's about
creating a form
to inform
people of this situation under under
this
weird assignment and so that's why
instead of just instead of just voting
the bill down last uh spring we decided
to retain it because these were just a
few like minor little issues so
yeah of course so but the process I
guess is that we have to get OLS to
amend it and then present the new
Amendment yeah
um but but that was what we were going
to decide to do
um and then what do we need Christina
for she's back
uh Christina do you have an email
address for Matt Hayes and we'll send it
over to Child Support
um through him because he's the one to
sign for this committee
do you know who I don't have his I don't
we want to send him what our intent I'm
just wondering if you have his email
address so I could send it to him
because we're going to send this to OLS
the changes we want and then with the
same time we'll send it to
the Bureau of Child Support Services
the way we keep everybody in hope that
this is why I bring my computer to these
so
and then once I get the email from her
with his email address then I can send
this to OLS we can have it drafted and
we'll have it ready to go to present for
um
to present for executive session that's
essentially it
um did anybody have any feedback
do you have any feedback
do you have any other recommendations
who okay
we need to fill out our form yep that's
all right
um
we're not doing anything yeah we're
going to do a
um adoption of amendment
okay
perfect
all right
so I sent that all right
changes to
my language
in sections
again because it's sent it's that's not
in a draft anymore
because I sent it oh you did oh yeah
I have a setting on that it delays my
scent items for like 10 seconds so that
so that if I have like oh I wanted to
add something I could just undo it and
then add that last like thought that
comes in after geez I may want it yeah
it's it's actually not it's a good
feature to have
so that I can undo things I only have
like 10 seconds to do it but if if one
more thing then I don't have to send
multiple emails I better do about five
minutes
changes to languages in sections one and
three and then remove
section two
all right so
we have a motion to that this will be
ought to passed once amended yeah okay
so moved by representative Moulton
second did by representative big fur
Okay and then we will
adopt emotion
to be adopted
at exec session
later
good yeah we'll just take a vote uh you
know me uh make the motion to amend it
as as you wrote it
which is in your I didn't get an email
now right right but we have to get the
amendment back so that I can put the
it's currently being amended well you
already said we did a motion well we
kind of did yeah that's why I just think
good
because I don't have the amendment
number yet so we can't adopt an
amendment that we don't have then let me
speak to what uh just say what you think
about the passive Amendment yeah he told
me to yeah
what are you moving that we're going to
pass it that uh we're going to ought to
pass it we're going to make a motion to
ought to pass with Amendment once we get
the amendment back but we are sending
and the amendment will remove
section two and we're changing language
to sections one and three that I read
out loud
good okay
I will second that okay perfect all in
favor all in favor aye
there we go
um
subcommittee chairman I guess that's you
did you get her did she get you that one
from that age she did oh okay yeah yeah
cannot recommend I mean you could put it
in an amendment if you want well we're
just filling this out you can't make a
formal recommendation you can't oh okay
you can't do that because you don't have
four
we do have a corner we've got two out of
three
uh you've technically have four because
representative discipline is on the city
oh she is I believe she was she was
supposed to be taken off
oh no so unfortunately you do not
perform that does not mean that you
could meet at any time between now and
the exact session even if it's half an
hour before okay uh but you can't make
it official uh recommendation
okay well I just in that case I'm going
to forward this to so D Simone you could
still uh
um
but she couldn't reply to you because
um that's a it depends on if you're
reporting to everyone so I'm not I'm
just sending it to those two
we still need you
yes you can still make the amendment but
hold on to it
wait executive session
um yeah yeah you can meet half an hour
at the time
we made this out does that mean we
should not make it out
uh I think it's okay but you can't you
cannot recommend OTP okay because you
can't make you do all that stuff no
decision you can keep it hang on to it
oh really but we don't turn it into you
well you can't because you don't have a
porn you can't make that recommendation
okay we thought we had a quorum because
we did we thought that D Simone was
taken off so we thought we had two out
no hang on to it okay and
thank you
children and family law session at some
point I don't know I don't think it's
scheduled yet so yeah sometimes it's not
till like December I'm not sure so uh
well no no is
um October
no no November okay um so and then you
know you'll have you'll have a little
bit of time so you could do it anytime
between now and before the executive
session to make that whole
recommendation but feel free to get your
Amendment please
what you mean to have another meeting or
like a mini meeting I guess but that's
why I'm emailing it to them so they can
at least read it and review it yep
that's that's far language that's good
okay we've done iPad so as long as as
long as you are not communicating via
email
you can certainly
you can't reply to a four monthly sure
so if it's all four of you that's not
okay but this is not public interest
it's complicated so it's like I just
want to communicate with people who
aren't here so no I only emailed it to
those too so since they're not I mean we
can't even adjourn
yeah
yeah we don't exist no you can't we
don't exist you just can't make
decisions okay absolutely your testimony
you can discuss you just can't I can
move this is that right yeah it's funny
because I want to a right to know
meeting with New Hampshire Municipal
Association they told us we can't even
this subcommittee to order for the
record I'm representative Peter Petrino
from Hillsborough 23 the town of Milford
and I serve as the clerk on on children
and family law what chairman has asked
that I chair this subcommittee on Senate
Bill 253 relative to parental access
to a minor child's medical records and
before we begin our discussion Miss
anyone out there have any comments that
they would like to make and come forward
and speak before this little
subcommittee
all right hearing none
then what I'll do is I will ask the
subcommittee members if they would like
to make some comments and and speak
speak to this bill
um sure I'll make some comments so um
I'm not in support of this bill I
brought my
um notes from the last time we discussed
this from the hearing and then our
executive committee
um and the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
um was opposed to this bill as were a
number of mental health providers and
doctors because they were concerned
about two things one was that it
introduces a new standard for abusive
neglect reporting that's inconsistent uh
with HIPAA right now state law says a
reason to suspect abuser neglect uh you
contact dcyf and you kind of let them do
their do their stuff and HIPAA the
health information Privacy Act says if
you have a reasonable belief that
there's abuser neglect that's when you
either contact dcyf and or consider
whether or not it would be appropriate
to release records and then this bill
will change that language to clear and
convincing and I just can't get behind
making that change because I don't see
how that's in the best interest of kids
so that's where I'm at
okay how about you uh representative
Nelson
thank you very much I am in support of
the bill but I'm willing to
um discuss some sort of compromise
um if if we are amenable to that I uh do
you feel that it's important for parents
to be able to have access to medical
records with certain exceptions because
it's their responsibility for the
well-being of their child I know that
there was some concern and some
discussion in the Senate hearing about
access to Patient portals
and being able to refill unnecessary
prescriptions and have information that
would be helpful for making important
Health Care decisions that minor might
not be prepared to make
um and and that's that's pretty much it
okay thank you very much so
all right so I've spent a lot of time
recently taking a look at this bill in
great detail and doing some research and
I have seen that this bill has come up a
number of times uh last year we had a
house bill back in 2022 we had House
Bill 1345 which was essentially uh the
same as the Senate bill before us and
that was uh interim studied uh in the
Senate this year we have a very similar
Bill House Bill 406 that is over in
health and human services it's nearly
identical to the bill that we have here
that too has been retained the bill
before us has been retained there has
not been a clear consensus with these
three bills in the last two years that
convinces me that this is something that
really is uh we should be moving forward
with to be honest I'm not even sure why
we need this bill in the first place
there was a question that was asked of
the sponsor uh the question was uh
why do we need this the sponsor Senator
Innis said simply it's a statement that
reinforces and reinfirms what already
exists
so that in and of itself tells me that
all of the protections that parents need
to have do in fact exist and of course
HIPAA is the overriding factor which um
decisions are made regarding
confidentiality looking back at the
house bill 406 representative uh Cole
fault simply said that there's nothing
in New Hampshire statute that
specifically asserts a parent's rights
to access and that's true we don't
because once again HIPAA uh oversees
everything he cited very specific
instances where Health Care Providers
cannot under HIPAA release certain
information so that in and of itself
tells me that every protection that
parents need to have in fact exists and
so the bills that have come before us
this bill here the house bill and of
course the bill from two years ago are
all moot
but all of that being said
we still have the house bill 406 I
reached out to members of Health and
Human Services I sent an email to the
committee did not get a response I
actually made a phone call last evening
to two members and spoke to them
directly and they said they do not know
yet when that bill will come up to their
subcommittee and so I think we can see
what they have to recommend and so at
this moment I have to be honest and say
that I'm sorry I voted to retain this
bill but right now I am looking at itl
no
no thank you
so we would go forward then we have
three out of four members and so our
recommendation is going to be to itl
this bill and uh without objection I say
we move forward with that and close uh
our subcommittee
we all in favor
do we need to take a
quick okay we just go forward uh an
official vote will be fine okay so I uh
would you like to make a motion uh sure
I'll move that we recommend itl I just
want to make sure that representative
Nelson's
is recorded thank you very much for that
okay so I will second that and we will
take we'll take a vote
yeah I guess no no go right ahead if you
would like to speak I just wasn't sure
we're gonna vote yeah no I think that
that's appropriate since we've made the
recommendation to itl but uh
representative Raymond is correct that
all positions should be reflected in
that vote
okay so representative Raymond uh yes I
vote Yes to itl representative Nelson no
and and I will vote uh yeah so that the
vote will be two to one itl is our
recommendation okay thank you very much
folks all right that was short and sweet
uh I'm going to call the
meeting to order on the uh subcommittee
review of House Bill 535
FN
and uh previously to our
meeting uh the information on the bill
and we had some data provided to us
through the great work of our
Christina Dyer and uh was sent to all
members for us to be prepared to
address what our intent would be in
terms of recommendation for action or
otherwise on 535
so that being said I'll open open the
meeting and if there's any comments from
our
visitors here today just just step up to
the table and you'll be recognized
immediately
so that being said and take advantage of
everyone's time uh do we have some
comments from our members
representative uh thank you Mr chair uh
I mean I think we could all agree that
there are
um
that attorneys in some of these
proceedings are necessary
um you know and that would be my
interest at least uh closing out this
term uh is to get a consensus with
both parties uh that that's absolutely a
necessity
and looking uh you know I'd be looking
to Define uh in a small
in a small way uh whom we could first
um get attorneys uh require attorneys to
get appointed to
um
you know then has the terms go on we
could redefine or add more I mean of
course this is a fiscal note added to it
so we're coming up with the policy if
the policy is too grandiose uh the
fiscal committee may not
you know may not be on board with us
um and that would be a on you know that
would be uh
uh too bad because we you know the
policy is the policy so uh that you know
that's what I'm looking for uh
um
in all proceedings of judicial branch
Family Division A minor child who was
subject to such perceiving shall be
entitled to representation so I I I am
not in agreement with that
my agreement would be with respect to
the uh family Family Court division
um for abuse and neglect uh children
only would be the first recommendation
any other any initial comments from from
members
well I'll just add one thing if I may is
and just in reading the bill
find myself seeing where the word May
and shall uh are present
and
specific to uh
to abuse and abuse
or neglect
is where the shell comes in but
when that's not there it has it has the
May and that and I mean for me that's an
inherent contradiction
uh in terms of um the uh well Mike from
a holistic approach to the
case being the whole case being heard in
court and for the appropriate uh
decisions to be made so that all
information has been presented at the
same or at the same hearing at the same
time
so and then the concern here was would
is this when there was
parents coming without representation
for themselves and then de facto for
that for the child
and this could open up a tremendous I
mean a very large
would it not open up a very large cost
item that we would need to fund
for this because as parents coming just
heard in previous testimony they're on
their own when they come to the cases in
some cases and children and family law
but that's what my concern my uh my when
I say concerned this may and shell that
I don't believe that that should be
these this should be split up in in this
case in in what we're talking about here
of ghostman
thank you chair
um so one thing to consider is we're not
fiscal here we're policy
um and to make sure that we're focused
on the policy piece
um
but also to include
representation for children that may be
placed
um
at a group home or out out of in an
outside facility
um that they are entitled as well to
legal counsel if I mean that's in a
neglect or abuse case but
that they should have access
if there's a contingency of them being
placed outside of into a group home or a
would that would that be before the fact
or uh meaning before a court case that
there that the child would already be
in residency as a group home
or that would be a determination of the
I think if it's determination if they're
going to be going versus I mean
so that they have
um representation once they are in there
I mean currently right now we have
kids that are not being represented but
going forward if we have this they would
have representation if there were issues
any any further comments on
what Grossman had to say
representative so just a clarification
so
uh for abuse and neglected cases uh you
would you would want to Shell for
um any child that has the potential of
that would be adding additional language
would not uh specifically or where would
that would be changing online five at
the court shell appointed attorney to
represent yourself the child
uh any recommendation of the guardian of
lineup yeah that would that would have
yep
yeah actually uh if if uh either Casa or
the child law the uh children's Law
Center
um
it's Jim and I don't know if they could
come up and
give us their recommendations
and and if you would just characterize
that question one more time
so they can specifically answer it
uh so with I'll spell 535 language so
we're looking to change this
um and
lines three to five uh the May appoint
an attorney representing interest of a
child but that's just uh involving all
neglected and abuse children under the
chapter so
um representative Grossman uh
was looking any child any abuse of
neglected case
that has the potential or actual outside
placement
it's it'll be a shell for uh attorney
representation right
um I'm Marcia sink I am the CEO of Casa
of New Hampshire and Caroline Delaney
host City with me is one of our staff
Attorneys at Casa so thank you for the
opportunity to speak
um
we are supportive of
that piece of a child who is in
placement out out of state
there was additional language that was
possible that was proposed that would
expand that in a way that we feel we
would not support and that is that a
child at risk of placement we currently
have about
well in any given Year we're serving
about 1600 children
who are in our abuse and neglect court
system and
um every you know so many of those
children are at risk of placement in and
out of state facility so it would open
up a very broad opportunity for that
appointment we are really supporting a
slight change to our current Statute in
169 C
which would allow broader appointment
for Council we agree that there there
are certain cases where absolutely our
our children and youth need an attorney
appointed and typically for very
specific or unique purposes
um educational severe educational
neglect cases Refugee and immigrant
cases where we need expertise from
attorneys on those types of cases are
residential out of state placements also
we feel that those kids that were
brought to light recently by the office
of the child advocate but we so we would
like to go back to the current statute
what we would suggest is going back to
the current statute providing a slight
Amendment which would say
specifically that at any point during
the proceedings any party to the case
could request the appointment of council
for a child and it would be at the
discretion of the court to make that
appointment and it's it's a change in
that that it currently only allows the
guardian ad litem who may be who the
child's best wishes may be in conflict
with are their best interests may be in
conflict with what the child wants and
it's only at that dispositional phase of
the proceedings all the child you know
the whole process for our for our kids
is that's the only opportunity for that
appointment what we're suggesting is
that we open up that opportunity that
again that any party could request
an attorney at any point during any one
of the proceedings so it could be after
the dispositional hearing when a child
is placed in a facility where we think
they need a attorney representation or
or any party on the case could make that
so just to clarify yeah currently the
gal can request counsel and that's right
now the only component we have had other
parties make that request and depending
depending on the circumstances is it the
judge's discretion it is at the Court's
discretion correct and some of our
judges in fact when we have requested an
attorney after the dispositional hearing
have said
we need one but the the statute current
currently reads that you've sort of
missed that window of opportunity so
this would allow the court to make that
determination at any point in the
proceedings
we also feel I mean just to sort of add
on that
um the resources that we have in the
state are so limited and I know that
there is sort of a larger push to have
more appointment their mandatory
appointments for our kids and the
potential cost of that and the resources
that we would use
um we just think could be used for
trauma-informed trauma-informed
therapists for our kids or other
services that families can access to you
know potentially
um
help rectify the situation that is at
hand and I our kids are so trauma
um damaged and there's so many
um as we all know lack of resources to
provide to them right now we'd love to
see those resources that potential
resources for appointment of council to
be used for other purposes
um the and I think that the other thing
that we see is on some of our cases when
there are attorneys appointed they're
doing an extraordinary job and others
they are really delaying the process and
permanency for our kids is delayed
because of continuances and and appeals
that are made so we would just add that
that smaller piece but it is but it is a
representative
thank you Mr chairman the
um
so so you're looking at
recommendation of a guardian ad litem
the court May appoint you're saying uh
add any party of the case the court
yeah we were suggesting just striking
um where the child's expressed interests
conflict with the recommendation for
dispositional orders of the guardian ad
litem
so that under this chapter it would read
the court May appoints an attorney to
represent the interest of the child in
any case brought abuse or neglect
brought pursuant to the chapter
so
and and just to clarify our attorney our
parents on all of our child abuse and
neglect cases are appointed counsel if
they are the petitioned party so they do
well if I'm if I'm if I may ask it is
that the
current the current language just
specific to the 535 bill in in the
amendment to 169 C 10.
is that
we you're in support of the language as
presented
except you're striking part of it no
we're not in not in 535 we're just oh
okay so you're not for 5 35 at all not
as it currently reads so not 535 at all
no sir yeah I like to talk in how we are
today not what happens tomorrow but oh
okay so it's like right now as the way
this bill is uh has is is was retained
that language I apologize okay no I want
to make sure I want to learn anytime you
speak I want to make sure I learn it
correctly here uh from you the thing um
in the note section when I say note the
methodology of the 535 Bill I'm assuming
you read that yeah I don't have it in
front of me but yeah well let's see just
go from maybe memory here but you know
where it says that
went in here
of the the changes
it's it's
doesn't change it it's not really making
any change of the the Court's ability to
decide whether or not to
uh determine representation for a child
and what I wanted to confirm for myself
is as a child is under 18.
we typically yes
typically a night well at the moment I
mean yes under 18 but if a child is in
the child if there is an open case a
child can extend their jurisdiction if
they have not graduated from high school
um so some of our are developmentally
just delayed uh young adults so
jurisdiction can be extended to 21.
okay just one final one it was just
saying that
with under the proposed amendment is
that it was still stating that the
decision of whether to appoint a child
and I'm just doing the narration here
a child and attorney remains in the
discretion of the court and is not
mandatory quote in all cases and I say
in quote to highlight that
that appears in my my opinion to be
where much conflict takes place is a
judge will say he's a dog on he or she
has a dog on Monday and a cat on Tuesday
on how they determine who gets
representation
and should we have more or should we not
use the word shell more in these part in
this
the evolution of this policy versus the
May what would be your recommendation we
don't agree with the shall appoint
um unless it's it's really carved out in
and and what what a unique circumstance
be a definitive
evidentiary proof of abuse and neglect
we feel very strongly that a child and a
child's attorney should not be part of
the adjudicatory hearing at least the
initial draft of the language that we
had seen was upon the filing of a
petition
and the reason for that is well there
are a few reasons
um if you have a child who is I mean
let's start with a child is
the victim of trauma regardless of
what's happened in the home it could be
domestic violence substance misuse
parents mental health a child should not
be responsible
um for being part of the process that
might of it throw their their family
into this system it should not be the
child's responsibility to
that shouldn't be part of the family
history going forward that a parent
might if a child is being honest about
what's going on what's going on in the
home that child could be responsible
for wow now dcyf is involved with our
family and the tension that could come
from that in addition I mean we've got
the potential of a child being
influenced by a parent to
perjure themselves to not give accurate
testimony or to tell their attorney not
to give don't downplay don't tell them
what was going on in the home and just
already for a child who's undergoing so
much it's so tumultuous and scary that
we should not have a child be part of
this system that the adults the the
people who have reported and are the
witnesses should be the ones responsible
so from Casa's perspective not having a
child have that responsibility so in
terms of the timing of if counsel were
appointed for the child that that
Council does not participate in proving
or disproving the petition that has been
filed regardless of the child's position
because a three-year-old might say I
want to go home I miss my mom but you
it's debatable and don't and I'm not
going to be funny but but that's what
this is about and what by about meaning
what the subject matter and I'm just
looking for guidance from our members
here is what is this appropriate
language Where We Are
notwithstanding the May in the show
or is what or how or how it's
operating now is that
the pro uh acceptable to in this case to
Casa I think that as as we said earlier
we're not in support of House Bill 535
um and
but we do recognize There's an
opportunity within our current statute
to expand that opportunity for
uh for uh for our courts to appoint an
attorney in in other circumstances so
it's just
we're just suggesting and again we're
we're suggesting as an aside to House
Bill 535 that there is an opportunity
for expand our current statute to be
more inclusive and to be able to provide
a broader opportunity for our courts to
appoint attorneys for children in this
one and that statute is 169. 169 c yeah
okay 10 10 10. all right thank you
representative long thank you Mr
in my notes I didn't hear any non-profit
that was in support of
Hospital 535 has written
so it's up to this subcommittee if we
want to do a deep dive and completely
put in language that's not in here that
that would be up to the committee I
don't know where you want to go with
that I like I said earlier I agree
um
you know I agree where a child shouldn't
be in the uh in the system making you
know even hearing those arguments with
parents and their attorneys
um I do believe that attorneys are
needed for the best interest of the
child I know Casa has the best interest
on a child
um but I do feel that I believe that
children would
um
would feel more empowered knowing that
whatever the result I had somebody who
was responsible to take care of me you
know uh which which I agree with so
I mean the more I look at what we're
discussing the change is a total
upside down
from this bill and I don't know if the
subcommittee wants to get into that
discussion to change the bill or wait
for legislation to come forward
next year or this year or 24 actually to
address this that that would be up to
the committee I I would say we I tell it
and because there is in my opinion too
much language that needs a change on
this
representative thank you Mr chair I
think it's just now we can this is
different it's my first time on this
kind of committee we can just discuss
things right like right now so one of
the things I think it's important to
keep in mind on this may shall language
is that when when kiddos you know
abusers will use whatever they can to
weaponize and they'll make it look like
they're the victim in the meantime but
coming out for these children
knowing that they're going to have to
have representation and we're not
leaving it up to the discretion of the
Court looking at the entire case and how
it's going it actually could be a bigger
problem because say you have an
eight-year-old and you automatically you
know put them and make them involved in
all this that eight-year-old doesn't
know anything different like what they
have at home is their normal so it's not
like they're going to come out and say
oh yeah this is abuse they don't get it
and so it really further weaponizes the
system unfortunately it's I think it's
meant you know it's in good faith to try
to make it better but it's one of those
cases where it can really further
weaponize it
representative thank you I actually
representative Seidel uh had fantastic
questions uh and we've got great answers
and that's when I was looking at this
saying
oh my goodness
that uh or answer it yourself the
current language needs a lot of change
as far as gossip is concerned in in HB
535 yeah yes oh yeah great and I would
ask the children Law Center to come
forward and ask if that's the same case
um OCA
uh Waypoint whomever wants to come up
with that same case and and I'm under
the impression that the answer will be
yes it needs a lot of change so we'll be
up to this subcommittee do we want to do
get something in this to have it
acceptable to us to bring It Forward
I don't know if we want to dig that deep
into
um you know into fixing this bill
okay as a subcommittee and then bringing
it to the full committee which they
didn't have the opportunity that we're
having
discussing this
and I do I'm in concert with
representative long I believe what this
needs is a Cooperative collaboration
with the Intelligentsia that we have
and to have a study committee on this
and the study committee is to give it
the time to do a bill that can be vetted
appropriately and you know for the
nuances it's not saying I don't I would
say everyone wants to do the right thing
the first time but it's to know what
what the collateral effects if now you
say open a door but when where and how
fast so it's uh that's what I I would
offer us to consider is a recommending
that this bill
not that a study committee be
representative
thank you chairman
or with reference
represent Greg in what she put forward
and with representative long and I do
agree that we're dealing with children's
lives and I do think we need to look at
this a lot more closely before moving
forward so I do concur with you that we
should do a lot more research before
representative question uh I don't know
if we could
could we could we
asked to study for a study Commission on
so it will be amended to be a study
committee
for a study commission I I'm not sure if
we could do that in the second year
okay so this has to be
uh ought to pass ritl has amended
okay
representative Grossman thank you is it
um do we know if
discuss that here if there is any are
any lsrs that have been filed related to
this legislation
because I think a study committee
I just would hate to keep putting it
farther down hoping that potentially if
there is some legis an LSR currently
maybe we could do some work this
session to get it going versus a study
committee which would just take longer
for these kids yeah so so uh that there
is uh however I'm not sure if the house
is going to accept it because we have a
bill uh with the same language I I know
I was turned down on a OLS filing
because there are Bills currently
retained that address that subject
okay
okay I and I absolutely understand the
non-profits this is an opportunity we we
some of us clearly know where we want
attorneys and and I get that this is an
opportunity and it's exciting that we
could revamp this bill to get what we
really want
however the more I think of it
the subcommittee has the knowledge this
is going to go to the full committee
which they're not going to have what we
have and and
I think that would make it more
complicated and and I wish to remain on
the safe side uh to get both parties
agreeing yes this is absolutely needed
here's where we're going to start uh
then then have a battle over this uh and
not set the policy in my opinion where
anything further from Casa
I'm the executive director of the
children's Law Center I think I can
probably speak loud enough do you need
me to
okay
uh so I'm I'm happy to answer any
questions I I um
I I would say that our so the children's
Law Center provides legal representation
to children involved in in child welfare
proceedings and at-risk children
generally but we do provide
representation to kids in 169 C
proceeding so so we have that experience
I I take it that the committee is
we are we are not interested in
advocating for counsel for children in
other types of Family Division
proceedings so so my comments are just
about 169 c
um I I without I'm not an expert on
legislative procedure but I I will say
that I do think the this this
subcommittee could
um could work on an amendment that is a
relatively robust Amendment to the
existing legislation
um if it
felt that it wanted to do the work now
and could bring it back to the main
committee I this is an issue that should
be addressed sooner than later by the
legislature children you have made
children parties to abuse and neglect
proceedings and as a matter of law they
are also victims but they are the only
party that does not currently have the
representation of counsel children have
extensive legal rights in 169 per C
proceedings they have legal rights that
are afforded to them in the child
protection act itself they have legal
rights through 170 g21 which is the
Foster children's Bill of Rights and
they also have due process rights so
they have constitutional rights but they
don't currently have a legal
representative to advocate for those
rights there are are 36 or 37 other
states Who currently afford children the
right to counsel in abuse and neglect
proceedings so there is a robust data
and research and and track records
established in other states I I
respectfully suggest that you don't need
a study commission we can certainly
provide you with research and data the
the uh the thrust of which is that the
best practices are to provide counsel
for children
I'm happy to
I'm happy to speak further about other
details to address some of what Marty
sink
said if you would like I I think that a
fully discretionary
um
the amending the the current bill such
that I I think this is what Casa has
recommended that the right to council
would be entirely discussion
discretionary so so that that's a
contradictory statement so it wouldn't
be a right to counsel but the the
ability to appoint counsel being
entirely discretionary in my view would
not get us very far uh children uh
children don't know to ask for lawyers
um and so I worry that a uh although a
fully discretionary a judge's ability to
appoint counsel
in any case uh is a is a step
further than
the way the statute is currently worded
it it is a very very small step uh and I
think the legislature can do better
representative long
uh thank you Mr chairman so right from
the get-go we have already have
conflicts between entities that have the
best
the best of children in mind and I
absolutely agree with all of your
entities that you do have the best
interests of the child of mine and then
I I love your advice to me I lean
heavily on that Vice
um so you consider you you called for a
robust
Amendment what are we talking about two
or three pages
no I I think we've got it down to a page
okay uh in in your opinion how much of
this current language in here would
change
and 535. so I don't have a I I worked
I'm familiar with I don't have a copy of
it in front of me but I I know that it
was a relatively minor change to the
existing language
um the the way
the way I see it there would probably be
if we do a Carvel that would provide the
absolute right to counsel in certain
cases so council at risk of placement
and we could we could probably drill
down on what risk means that would be uh
additional language
um
uh there might be addition there might
be other language that makes uh that
that makes provides a path for a child
to be advised about the right to counsel
so that might be an extra provision
um
we also would want to suggest to the
legislature for inclusion in this
legislation that the attorney have the
right to access records it is currently
very difficult for us to access our own
clients records in these proceedings and
so that would be something we would want
the legislature to consider but this is
these are I mean this is discrete
language I'm just sort of giving you the
bullet point list currently the statute
allows uh attorneys well children who
have attorneys appointed for them allows
the attorneys to petition the court for
funds for services other than Council
that is Money Paid through the Indigent
defense fund
we'd like the legislature to include in
the legislation a procedure that allows
attorneys to make that request without
input from the other parties in the the
same way that those requests are made
made in delinquency and adult criminal
legal proceedings so those are some of
the bullet points
so I believe there was five or six
changes that's not currently in here
that's right so
um
it may be simple to delete a line but
but you're adding five or more which
I'm not seeing that there's a consensus
on with all the entities that have the
best
interest on a child in mind so that's
what the complication is because my
understanding is
um
my understanding is this retained bills
have to
be out
by uh November 15th or November 17th
you know and I don't know if the
committee has a hole
um could do their due diligence and all
those changes
I understand the urgency
I understand there is language there's
other language in the other 35 States
um
you know but again we're dealing with
Hospital 535
and it's up to the subcommittee whether
we feel that
we want to
redo it
or you know and I'd be in favor of
redoing it
if it was a lot if it was
related to me a little simple you know
simplified which I'm not hearing that it
is uh and you know uh
due diligence of the full committee I
think would be missing and I would be
afraid uh that we may not be heading
down the right Road and that would be
that would be you know a complication uh
so yeah I personally I believe again
that uh
we're on itl 535 and uh
get bills in for this year
um to the to the Senate no uh for the to
Ms Wilford one uh
question mark a comment and ask your
guidance
in the in uh line three on the bill
where it said this isn't where it's uh
the changes on this on this effort was
in cases involving a neglected or abused
child
only
it wasn't talking uh across the board
would that not be a defect in the bill
inherently
again children playing a role in in the
cases come for children and family law
aren't that aren't there are those
neglected and abused but we'll have that
uh label put on them put on them in that
case but there's also other other
challenges like uh that could be taking
place and I don't have the legal correct
legal terms to use
but do we need more of an more of an
open description than uh and and then
what we have here which just says in
cases of neglected and abused
well if you're not neglected or abused
but there's other uh it could be medical
issues you know that dealing with with
um a child a uh a minor let me let me
see if I
I'll answer the question the way I
understand it and you you tell me if I'm
I'm not giving you the the answer no I
want your answer not what I'm telling
you it should be no well so uh
so
my organization provides representation
in abuse and neglect cases and and so
that is our Focus we we
um
our clients typically are growing up in
poverty there's a very large
intersection
between children growing up in poverty
and the abuse and elect and neglect
process children in in the legislature
has identified children as parties in
abuse and neglect proceedings and and I
don't I don't think that that that is
I'm not an expert in other areas of
family law and so I can't I can't tell
you much there but my impression is that
children probably are not parties to
those proceedings in abuse and neglect
cases the the caption of the case is the
child's name in the interest of child's
name
um and so what what other states have
determined and what we think is the best
practice is that children who are
victims of abuse and neglect who will
have decisions made in their cases which
which carry out over the course of well
it should be 12 months but typically
much longer in abuse and neglect
proceedings that children have the
opportunity to have legal counsel and
legal advocacy in those cases which will
determine the balance of the course of
well that's a debating point and you
know and I what's debating on it is what
is the primary issue that can be proved
uh but and by proving in a court
environment and uh and
and if it's not necessarily abuse or
neglect I mean again with that's that
particular Silo as I'll call it but
there's medical issues developmental
disabilities and so on when they're
doing their best but it's not happening
and uh and they meaning the parent
parents or parent and it's just looking
here when do they have a a court
represent representative for that
specialty
and not not for a crime per se but for a
specialty and not just seeing how broad
this this broader this could be
yes it could be I mean that's an access
to Justice question uh probably and
there are many gaps in our legal systems
where we don't provide attorneys who
would be very helpful for people who
need them but this we've identified as a
very particular and acute need for
representation right I did consider I
did consider you my access to Justice by
the way so from what I was hoping you
provide some guidance in that regard uh
that being said
when I um offer I mean I'm just going
back to my history I've been been here
over 20 years and uh in in terms of uh I
say a study committee not just a code
word for it needs more work okay and uh
and this and and I'm one that does so
let's get it done while we're young so
it's it's that to have it done before
the end of the of the term and it's
either a recommendation you know uh for
what the wording is or it's continued
for a build to be file filed for the
next session in the fall I think of 24.
but uh not for me I'm not about delayed
taxes or anything it's just say we we
have tremendous assets you being one
that to help on this and then but to do
it right the first time and uh and and
again that's why it was bringing up the
term study committee uh so that this
would continue but that's with support
of the recommendation of of all members
here but I saw that this does need more
work and has long pointed out well don't
have to repeat what the gentleman said
you know it's work is needed on this and
this is
the classic case it's not ready for
prime time and uh so the night no no
you're not supporting the bill is
written would that be a correct
statement that's correct thank you
Joanna finally okay
got an answer of yes from you uh but
anyway that was it uh for myself that
representative
thank you chairman so my question would
be if there's a way because
we have two wonderful organizations here
that are thinking in what I'm saying is
thinking a little differently but is
there a way to find a common area where
we can make some changes to moving
forward but still keep it on the table
so that we still can add to it so we're
not waiting a whole nother you know year
or so but we could somehow find a
compromise that's going to meet the
needs of the children and start the
process moving forward and then still
come back and and think about how could
we make this better
is is that a possibility
I I think that's always possible
um
when we have we have had we've had had
discussions with Casa and I should point
out that New Hampshire legal assistance
is also here as is the disability rights
Center
um and so we have engaged in those
conversations I don't think it's out of
the question that we could could
continue to have conversations
it
it is a possibility we have not yet uh
we have not yet found
Common Ground entirely
but not entirely but at least a starting
point
well I think we agree that the we agree
with Casa that the fully a Court's
ability fully discretionary ability to
appoint counsel is
is a step in the right direction we just
don't think it's a step far enough and I
think that Casa would say that what we
are proposing is a step too far uh and
so that's that's where the
so we can find that middle ground to
start just to get the ball going and
then come back so we don't end up with
something where we're asking too much
that is a good plan I'm sorry
I'm done
did you have a comment
sorry back to this one so I think that
that is I think we're all working
towards a progressive language and stuff
I just don't think we're going to find
it in 5 35 I mean it basically is like a
a gutting of this of what um
representative Hill wanted in the
beginning too so I just think yes I
agree we need legislation and there are
ways to go about it that's
more amicable I think but I I'm
continuing on with what representative
long said that this I think this should
be itl I think it just is a full
skeleton project at this point with uh
so far two people disagreeing with the
anything further Miss waffle no thank
you so much all right thank you for your
time today
representative long
thank you Mr chairman so so uh I I see I
believe where representative ball is
going
um you know if there's a small bite that
we could do
um that's
not a lot of changes
I mean I can only speak for myself I'd
be willing to meet two or three times
before the end of October on this
subcommittee to get that simple language
that could be easily
um you know easily explained to the full
committee
instead of uh all the vessels that that
you wanted to add to it which I'm open
to and I agree that it may be in the
best interest
um so
if we if we could get agreement with
those involved with
you know something that starts this off
because I think that if we can get a
positive
policy on this
uh in January because I believe that's
when it would come to the house floor by
both parties agreeing I think that
starts us off in the right direction for
the for
24 to get some tweaks
um so I don't I don't know if that would
be possible Mr chairman or or you know
what what the rest of the committee is
thinking that this time
my view is with with the respect to
representative long that I would not
want to support that uh that's a death
of a Thousand Cuts in my view and uh is
to do it I'm not just I like to walk the
talk but let's do it right the first
time and that's why I was recommending
the the study committee that we really
look at the bill that 535 be in the
vehicle that we can utilize it do
something to be voted on before the end
of the term
uh but quite a lot to do like just part
of it and then see how it works out that
will be a delayed tactic not not by us
but by others in the next term and
we then this will be continued on at you
know ad hominem and I that's why I would
not
I would ask we not consider that
strategy it's either we do a total
revamp of the bill I mean uh as opposed
to it yelling which means it's it's on
the Hiatus and until a new bill uh is
generated
but still work has to be done as to how
would that bill and the wording of that
bill be brought to the table
and they'll collaboratively
so I mean so that that's where I
thank you Mr chairman and uh I I
I could agree with uh with what they
just said however studying a house bill
uh 535 is like uh I'm gonna turn my uh
63 Dodge Dart that has flat tires
the engines
burnt uh into a Ferrari
um because this isn't not the place to
start we we all agree that this isn't
the place to start so that that's
you know again
there's two choices in my mind one is to
itl 535
or the other one is to get a uh much
smaller agreement with everybody
um that the concept
of uh attorneys for uh abuse of
neglected children
um is a concept that we all agree with
agree with
uh for
you know the health session in January
which I'm thinking this will be coming
up and then uh work towards uh better
language uh as we move forward
um so that and that would be up to the
uh
uh to the subcommittee um you know I
mean as far as I'm concerned uh
hey thank you did the uh Disability
Rights
folks have any comment to make or would
yeah I wanted to take advantage of you
thank you I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center I think that Lisa Wilford
actually spoke for the group that I'm
involved with the juvenile rights policy
group and that consists of Waypoint the
ACLU New Hampshire legal assistance the
children's rights the children's Law
Center
um who am I missing new Futures uh I
think I got like everyone got everyone
and I mean
we really think that there needs to be
the changes that Lisa Wilford outlined
we need to have a right established for
children to have counsel when they're at
risk of placement in congregate
facilities
Bledsoe is a good example of what
terrible things happen when children are
sent out of state and children need to
have someone in their Corner an attorney
and we understand that the judge's role
is to make a decision about what's in
the best interest of the child that
Casa's role is to present to the court
about what's in the best interest of the
child it's also in the best interest of
the child to enable them to have a voice
in these proceedings that really
directly impact their lives
so it's a step forward to expand
discretion for a court appointment but
it's really not what's in the best
interest of the children
in our state who are at risk of
placement at some pretty
challenging facilities where they're
even if it's a good facility they're
being separated from their friends their
schools their families and to have
someone in their corner to assist them
is really important it's also what Most
states do across the country I think New
Hampshire is one of only a handful that
doesn't guarantee a right to counsel for
children independency cases
so maybe this isn't the vehicle to do
that but
we really hope that this committee and
that the legislature will fully consider
the importance of guaranteeing a right
to counsel for really vulnerable
children
thanks what was your full name again
it's always Ms Rosenberg to me you can
all right thank you any anything oh
thank you very much Mr Rosenberg thank
you oh Karen I should say and um legal
assistance did they would you give any
comments to what we haven't given
comments
um my name is Michelle wonger and I'm
from New Hampshire legal assistance and
I I Echo everything uh my colleagues
from the disabilities rights Center and
the children's Law Center have said I
think what's really interesting about
this issue is there's so much agreement
with the benefits that Casa brings to
the table
um and then there's also agreement that
they're in in certain certain
circumstances that they really need is a
need for Council to bring a legal
perspective to the child and I think
there was a conversation earlier about
about attorneys sort of getting in the
way of finding permanency for kids and I
think what's challenging about that
perspective is that
if a child has counsel the council's job
isn't to blindly say child you want to
go home that's what I'm going to argue
you for that's not what an attorney does
what an attorney does is talk to the
child about their perfect world and
really flush out what the child wants
why they want it and then talk to the
child about options as an attorney who
has represented kids in all kinds of
different Juvenile Justice cases
one of the most important things
attorney can do is know about all of the
options available to a child and then
what their legal rights are to pursue
those options and then use the law to
pursue those options for them and when a
child is in court and they're told that
the only options for you are to go home
to an unsafe environment or go to a
facility like Bledsoe and nobody knows
all their rights to other legal options
and how to vigorously pursue those legal
options that child is at a disadvantage
so under current Supreme Court law we
think the bare minimum is that there is
a full discretionary right to council
which must include notification to a
child of their right to request counsel
but we think that that leaves a child
children at a severe disadvantage to
actually access counsel and reap the
benefits of legal advocacy to not only
pursue their desires but truly be
counseled on the array of legal options
available to them and how to move those
those desires forward and so that's the
reason why we're in support of an
expanded legislation we're happy to
continue working with Casa to find
Common Ground there was a time we
thought that might be close and you know
I think things have moved in the right
direction but I'm still optimistic that
there is space for common ground and I
hope to continue working through this
process with them ideally this session
either here in this committee or in the
Senate
any questions representative law
uh so Michelle do you think House Bill
535 is the
legislation
I was disappointed to hear that perhaps
another bill couldn't be brought in this
in this session if that one were to die
um but no I don't think that that's my
favorite vehicle to bring this forward
um if there's another vehicle to bring
this forward in a way that you know
isn't years down the road I would I
would love to look at those options
right so so and just to confirm uh you
actually you also agree with the urgency
of something going I do I believe that
the current law is not compliant with
federal law because it does not allow a
judge to exercise full discretion and
appointment of counsel and if that were
to taken on appeal to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court I think that the current
law would likely be invalidated very
good thank you
with anyone else like to offer some
comments
nope
I know we've been mentioned a couple
times here today my name is Alyssa
Matthew I'm the attorney for the office
of child advocate
um we work closely with all of the
groups that are here today we don't sit
specifically on that policy group but we
have certainly talked to all of these
different groups after the Bledsoe
report we've also talked with a number
of legislators including chairman
Pearson and representative long
um I just wanted to mention from the
office of child Advocates view we agree
with the idea that the Court's ability
to appoint counsel should be expanded to
any point in a Judicial proceeding in
the abuse and neglect Arena as has been
stated here and should not be predicated
just on a conflict with Casa beyond that
there are a lot of great ideas in the
room the one that the office of child
advocate feels quite strongly about
based on our Bledsoe report is the need
for children in the abuse and neglect
Arena that are currently in residential
placement or at risk of residential
placement shall have attorneys
based on what we saw from that Bledsoe
report one of the boys that were in that
facility did in fact have a casa and
Casa had a very difficult time accessing
that child that we believe an attorney
would not have had quite the same
barriers and that was a 169 C case so I
just wanted to to bring that for forward
that those are the pieces that the
office of child advocate feels very
strongly about that residential
placement
peace and we do believe though there are
guard rails potentially definitions
around what at risk of residential
placement
could mean
um perhaps HP 535 is not the vehicle
there has been some legislation put
forth around our recommendations from
the Bledsoe report by the house and
discussions with other representatives
think anything further
okay we thank you very much for your
comments
is there anyone else would like to offer
their
comments
um I think it it stops this vehicle
which has been determined by many here
to not be the right vehicle but it
doesn't mean that that's the only you
know thing that we have for this session
or whatever but I do I do think
back to Pat's you know analogy of the
cars and stuff we can't take this
clunker in I just think it's like it's
just too much I think this one has to be
ideal I don't think that
um this is in the best interest of
anyone to try to work with this
thank you
um I respectfully disagree with with
representative Greg
um I think that the longer we've put
this off the more children are at risk
for having greater issue in what they've
been going through without legal
representation I think there is some
some work that we could do on this as it
is to
it is needed without
causing other further issues and further
delay
the only concern I have is like
representative ball had said because
there's a fiscal note that we cannot
present anything with the physical note
coming so I'll uh
if you'll accept the motion I'll move
that we recommend to the full committee
itl
here we have relate them
we have a motion to itl do we have a
is there any further comment from
members
then I'll call for the vote
representative Grossman
yes
representative
Greg yes
representative long yes
representative ball
yeah
so in terms of recommending Ito
that is not a recommendation for us
to take the place of that is
to utilize representative long
suggestion and that is to have a couple
more meetings on this
but the attempt of having an amendment
uh done on this bill
and to see if we can be successful this
in this term
uh and that's such your recommendation
was one that is uh achievable within the
so if I may yeah representative long
thank you Mr chairman so yeah I
I agree that that's possible with this
it's not the full alphabet in my opinion
it has to be uh for the due diligence of
the whole the committee as a whole uh
because this will be coming to the floor
uh of the whole committee at the end of
August I believe
um so uh
you know to take a smaller bite that
everybody could agree with
I think
um you know I I think would be
better for my best interest in getting
attorneys for children
um I I don't like the three to three
uh and it's a party division this is not
a party issue and I don't want that
perception to be out there
um so if we could get the groups
together to make some recommendations to
us that could
again
uh helping this issue if if that's at
all possible then I'd be willing to meet
a couple times to see if we can't get
that done so
um I is there a motion needed uh missed
wire
on on uh
or or do we just adjourn uh to uh meet
right
okay
go ahead representative ball
I was just wondering if we can request
that those who spoke submit their
a request yes as you're a representative
ball asking for the guidance in a
written format and therefore when we
have our next meeting
as I'll say
I'll say in two weeks just to give time
for for those who made their comments
today so we can have it emailed to us
and uh and then all members can be
prepared so that when we meet again uh
we'll be fully loaded with the
information and then with what
recommendations to make for a amendment
to this bill and and then we can take at
that time a definitive uh vote of either
recommend the uh the change in the
language
uh or or to ytl
to see if see if this goal could be
attainable in that in that time frame
so
representative ball
no ball I'm sorry website long thank you
um she has a very large influence wow my
hair looking that good all right
I know it does yeah yeah I I like when I
heard some of the discussion
um for example uh it seemed like there
was a connection with respect to those
that are in placement
however not uh those with the potential
of being in placement so I mean
something that we could
grab onto
um because the the whole you know what
what some entities want
I can agree with that
um but I don't think there's the time
frame with which to uh with which you
know the rest of the committee will have
their due diligence and and absorbing it
um so
any anything that can be agreed upon
potential language on uh you know
Crossing out whatever needs to be
crossed out adding whatever you you all
agree with
you know I think that gets us on the
upper leg with respect to uh partisan uh
making it not partisan and uh best
interest of the child so that would be
appreciated
is there a question from the audience
you may approach the mic so we
I would just say that we would like we
would be happy to meet with a group and
see what we can
um come to agreement on
um and bring that to the committee I
don't know if you're in agreement with
that agreement
going back to the table
and working with
our partners in this
and then bring something forward and
just an amendment which would be an
which I I'm assuming as it needs to be
in the form of an amendment for to 535
yes
and that that would be uh legal
assistance developmental disability casa
casa
in office of child advocate sure so
uh children excuse me children law as
well so we have those entities
I mean just getting together so there'll
be some language that can be provided
then to us I think we can make yeah sure
I mean if it's either it's possible or
if
it's either possible or not but let's
see if we can make something happen that
being said would a um
oh do you want to schedule another
meeting that's right I was going to see
what was rational based on the schedules
here would be like two weeks from now
now for us to have a meeting again
so we'd have to have the narratives from
from you so we could have have them read
and be prepared for if I'm correct the
deadline would be November 17th that you
bring this to
okay
so my name is Chairman I've
representative long yes so I'm looking
at uh we do have some subcommittee
meetings uh CFL subcommittee meetings on
Tuesday the 10th
um but I I only got one maybe I'm
I'm on just that one committee yeah
subcommittee
well before we then get to the date what
uh I would be an assumption of when uh
you would have a document of the
recommendation ready for ready to
provide to the subcommittee prior to and
then we would meet after that I don't
want to make the decision for all of us
yeah but um just a guess but two to
three weeks all right so with this then
the week of the 16th of uh October so
during that week and the question to see
what uh if not if not Tuesday
are you still directing your Mana not
Tuesday
well we can have a room in the cafeteria
everyone will show up then so so can we
do Monday or Wednesdays
which which is the best day uh that
um
yeah which which it will be yeah it will
be yeah so so
um so so Monday the 16th
Monday the 16th
and uh
for 11 8 11 A.M
yeah I got a Sonoma Youth Center service
center oversight committee meeting at 10
A.M on Monday the 16th
well
are you looking for me to leave uh Mr
chairman no no no no no leave the
on the 16th
oh that's at two o'clock all right so
okay
well we have a scheduling yeah
the 16th just identified
no
the afternoon
yeah we could see if there'd be a room
available
all right one o'clock Wednesday the 18th
that one one pm
and and if and then the the
main the main point there is for the
team to have their uh written
recommendation for language uh sent to
us and uh maybe can have a sense
well our emails are out there
but um
to uh I think to Ms Dyer yeah and uh
then miss diode then we'll make sure she
gets gets it to the subcommittee and uh
as early as you know prior to the that
meeting so we'd be fully prepared to
as a subcommittee to discuss with you
and have your description of the
application of the language
a shorter meeting I would say
for that
that agreeable to all members sure
and that's agreeable because it doesn't
happen without you folks making that
report take place okay then that's
that's what we're gonna do and
Ms Dyer you'll have that formally
scheduled
yes
and uh but we will not have the benefit
of your
appearance
yeah
no we don't need I don't even placement
but I mean if um your maybe your written
comments on is it have that and uh and
then that can be put we can have that
part of our discussion
okay
just one question can the courts be
involved in this group conversation
because it has huge impact on on them
only if it can be appealed
yeah no absolutely okay yeah I think it
would be helpful to have their voice
involved in this
yes and to be part of our committee
conversation as well hopefully
absolutely thank you nope yeah thank you
perfect policy though
you know
so do we just close this here yes are we
in refill could we just close it yeah
yeah well okay well with nothing further
what's taking place is we'll await a
narrative from the Consortium that's
going to be meeting here to give
recommendation of of language to get it
to us prior to our uh meeting on the
18th on Wednesday so that we are not
seeing it for the first time we're going
to prepare to have to read it and then
to have questions and then
clarifications
with the goal of with the gold evil of
approving or if if not we will have a
vote on itl in the bill
that that is the that is the intent
unless there's something con contrary to
that from members
so we're going to have action taking
place with based on the work uh that the
professionals can bring to us
and so pending that uh if there's
nothing further I will call a meeting at
uh 12 25 to an end and thank you very
very much for being part of making this